My name is Hussein Fancy.
My name is Allison Didychuk.
My name is Binyam Mogessie.
I'm Tesca Fitzgerald.
I'm Nurfadzilah Yahaya.
I am C.J. Argue.
I am Mengxia Liu.
My name is Jane Lynch.
I am a scholar of medieval Europe
and the Islamic world.
I work on herpes viruses, which are
incredibly common human pathogens.
I'm a historian of Southeast Asia.
My lab studies
fundamental mechanisms of human reproduction.
My research is in robotics,
interactive robot learning.
Ultimately, we want to make electronic devices
that can be used for energy applications in the future.
I specialize in Islamic law and colonialism
and I work with at least five languages
Arabic, French, Malay, English, and Dutch.
I'm a sociocultural anthropologist
and what I'm particularly interested in is how
ethical and moral questions
emerge in the context of economic life.
I take people to the Middle Ages
because it is a foreign country for them.
It is a place that they will be detached
from everything they understand of the world
and return them to the present as changed people.
We hope to make fundamental discoveries concerning the basis
of human infertility.
The virus that I work on
is called Kaposi's Sarcoma Associated Herpes Virus,
which is interesting because it can cause cancer
in immune compromised individuals.
As a historian of Southeast Asia
and as someone who is actually from there,
I think that I offer a unique perspective on the region.
I'm in the Energy Science Institute
and the idea of having that institute
is to gather faculty from different departments
who are working on energy applications
so people can work together and collaborate with each other.
Do corporations have a social responsibility?
Should we try to create
social change through the things that we buy at stores?
These are the kinds of questions that I center my courses around
but also that emerge within the context of the research that I do.
An experience of math as a social activity,
appreciating that it's something that is best done
through collaboration and experimentation,
working with other people
and being willing to mess up together
and then get on the right track together will ultimately lead
to a much deeper appreciation for the material.
What I hope to achieve from here is things that would
not have been possible in other places.
That is, scholarship
interactions and collaborations across different disciplines.
We are working on a very interdisciplinary research
that will combine
material science, chemistry and electrical engineering.
I hope to build a strong, happy lab full of scientists
from all walks of life.
I'm excited to teach.
I'm excited to expose some of the best students in the country
to the material that I find fascinating and interesting.
There's still a lot of unsolved problems out there.
And so what I really hope to do
is to take these natural curiosities and interests
that students have about A.I. and robotics
and turn that into questions that they want to solve.
My hope here is not only to perform
cutting edge research,
but also to teach students from diverse backgrounds,
to be a role model,
to send a message
that this is really achievable for everyone.
I want them to learn
the way to solve a problem
and how they think is very important
beyond the knowledge in the textbook.
To encourage them to be attentive
to very ordinary things, to slow down
and become observers of the world
around them
and things that seem
mundane or irrelevant,
but that end up being the small details
that open up very large worlds.
What we're doing in the hour and a half that we're together,
we're cultivating a sense of how to understand and question
the world in front of us, and also how to shed
an alarming sense of certainty that so many people have
that they know what the world is.
I think that becomes part
of a lifelong journey of self understanding.
Research problems are problems that by definition
have not been solved by anyone before.
And so there's going to be a lot of obstacles.
So the biggest question isn't necessarily
how much do you know about this topic,
but rather how long are you willing to stick with this
and continue to learn even after you make mistakes
and even after an approach doesn't work
until you come across the right solution?
I think that kind of stubbornness is ultimately
what makes a researcher successful.
Being at Yale offers us the scientific tools and facilities
to perform our research at the higherst level.
I was an undergraduate at Yale many years ago,
so part of the appeal was to return to a place that I love.
What attracted me to Yale was the Yale History Department,
which is a top history department internationally.
What attracted me to Yale is just how much
computer science and engineering are growing here.
Everybody is so invested in teaching
as much as they are in their own scholarship and learning.
I feel like there's this very palpable sense that
learning here is like a connection to a lot of history
that has happened on this campus.
There's a sense that there is more at stake here
than just the immediate task at hand.
And I'm very excited to be a part of that
kind of a community and connect with a bigger sense
of what we're really doing here.
All the faculty members and the chair and the dean,
they are very helpful and supportive of new faculty members
and they really want the junior faculty member
to be successful at Yale.
Part of what I loved about being at Yale
and part of what drew me back here
was that I I was an English major as an undergraduate.
I never took a history class as an undergraduate
but I've returned as a history professor.
And to me that says a great deal
about the kind of education I got here,
The liberal arts themselves at Yale.
And I'm excited to be a part of
a community where we teach people
how to read, to think
and the ways in which it imbues their lives
in really surprising ways.